This parabola has a vertex at 1, 2. Excellent work if you figured it out. We
want to start by factoring a negative 3 from these first two terms so we'll
have negative 3 times x squared minus 2x. We'll leave a space in order to
complete the square and then we'll have negative 1 on the end. The b value is
negative 2 here. So, we need to add b over 2 squared in order to complete the
square. B divided by 2 equals negative 1, and this number squared is positive
1. This means, we add 1 in order to have a perfect square here. But, we really
just didn't add 1 here, we really subtracted 3. We'll have negative 3x squared
here, positive 6x here. And negative 3 here. So, in order to make our equation
balanced, we'll have to do the opposite of negative 3. We'll have to add 3 to
the same side of the equation. This is so that we really add 0. We don't want
to change our equation, we really just want to leave it balanced. We can
rewrite this as a perfect square, writing x minus 1 squared to replace this
trinomial. The factor of negative 3 stays in front, and then we combine
negative 1 and positive 3 to get positive 2. This is our equation in vertex
form. And we can see that the vertex is h, k. Positive 1 and positive 2. Keep
in mind the y value were equal to 2, then that means that this entire
expression would have to equal zero. Which means the binomial x minus 1 must
equal 0. So, we set it equal to 0, which means x would have to equal 1. That's
the x coordinate of our vertex. So, we have this for our vertex, and then we
can get two other points by moving one left and one right of the vertex, and
then three units down. We can see that more clearly here. One unit left and one
unit right, and then three units down. That's our a value. So, we have the
points 0, negative 1 on our parabola, and we have the point 2, negative 1. And,
notice that these y coordinates are three units less than our vertex.